typically the goal of machine learning
is to generalize about a set of data
however sometimes it's possible to
recover information about specific
training examples from a train model how
can we provide more privacy and ensure
our models captured general patterns
rather than specific examples stay tuned
to find out welcome to AI adventures
where we explore the art science and
tools of machine learning my name is Yu
Feng Guo and on this episode we're going
to take a look at tensorflow privacy a
new tool aimed at making and easy to
train models with privacy last year
Google published a set of responsible AI
practices focused around fairness
interpretability privacy and security
one of the recommended practices in the
privacy section States appropriately
safeguard the privacy of m/l models and
recommends that we train ml models using
techniques that establish mathematical
guarantees for privacy this is all well
and good to recommend but it does leave
you wondering how exactly do I do that
when you train a machine learning model
the goal should be to learn these
general patterns not facts about
specific training examples otherwise the
model ends up memorizing a set of
specific facts which may not generalize
well to previously unseen data and may
lead to possible exposure of the
underlying data that was memorized this
is especially important when that data
set corresponds to user actions or user
attributes of course it's not enough to
say that your model probably doesn't
memorize specific users data what we
want is to use techniques that offer
strong mathematical guarantees that
models do not learn or remember any
details about any specific user
tensorflow privacy does just this all
without needing any expertise in privacy
or understanding its underlying
mathematics so what's happening under
the hood in order to ensure that no
single example can impact that final
train model tensorflow privacy
introduces some modifications to the way
that gradients are calculated during the
training process gradients are a way of
expressing which direction and how far a
model should update its internal state
represented by weights and biases or put
another way of large matrix of numbers
and typically during a single training
step we use a batch of data just some
subset to determine the gradient and
then apply it to update the value of the
weights so in other words we look at
some bit of the data figure out based on
that which direction and how far to
shift our model and then we go there
tensorflow privacy makes a few small but
key tweaks to how that gradient is
computed if a single example is
providing an outsize effect on that
model's gradient it may cause it to
stick out so to speak and thus
potentially be exposed in the train
model one example of how tensorflow
privacy addresses this is by averaging
together multiple mini gradient updates
on a subset of the full batch so each
mini gradients value is clipped limiting
its range of possible values and so that
restricts their individual impact these
mini gradients are then averaged
together and finally we add some
gaussian random noise on top of this
average so by doing this we're ensured
that no individual example will be
memorized by the model in practice you
don't need to modify your model
architecture or training procedures to
take advantage of tests or flow privacy
instead to train models use a different
optimizer provided by the tensor flow
privacy library and we'll fill in some
values to customize the optimizers
clipping noise level and number of mini
batches to average together yes we're
gonna introduce some more hyper
parameters for you to tune but hey it's
better than than rewiring your entire
model and it's better than exposing your
users data now let's take a look at an
example of what tensor flow privacy can
achieve in their blog posts announcing
the launch the team highlighted an
interesting situation with a language
learning model which is supposed to
identify English sentences that look
like they come from financial news with
the two models side-by-side one trained
using tensor flow privacy and one
without
there are many sentences where both
models agreed on say sentences that look
like financial news such as South Korea
and Japan continue to be profitable but
then there were the ones which the
models disagreed on these were notable
because while the data set had marked
these sentences as financial news they
definitely don't look like they belong
in financial news what's interesting
here is that not only do these anomalous
sentences account for most of the
differences in accuracy between these
two models but this really illustrates
the idea that going by metrics purely
it's not always the right decision it
also suggests that perhaps we can
utilize tensorflow privacy and similar
tools to identify aspects of a data set
which perhaps shouldn't even be there in
the first place
tensorflow privacy turns the science and
math behind differential privacy into a
tool that you can use and while the
tuning of hyper parameters does remain a
bit of an art the team has offered up
some reasonable initial values to begin
your exploration for more details and
examples head on over to the blog post
I've linked below in the description
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud AI adventures and if you enjoyed
it hit that like button and be sure to
subscribe to get all the latest episodes
right when they come out for now check
out tensorflow privacy to make machine
learning safer for your users
[Music]